okay thanks um
i want to start by thanking the
organizers for organizing this workshop
and
inviting us to give these talks uh so
i'm going to
uh give the first in in in four talks in
a series of four talks
on this topic which received a lot of
attention
in in the last decade or so
so let's just start so we all know
what the classical coding problem is but
let me remind you
what it is so suppose you have two
parties uh
who want to communicate the one of the
parties has this input x which is an n
bit string
and wants to send that string over to a
second party
but they can't he can't just send the
string
in the clear because some of the
transmissions will have errors
okay uh how do we solve this problem
it's it's a problem that we've studied
for a long time
and uh today we know a lot about how to
solve it
solve it we know that you can take this
string and
encode it into an error correcting using
an error correcting code
so you take the short string that's n
bits long and encode it into
potentially a longer string using this
encoding function
in such a way that um if you transmit
now this
code word uh then even if there are
errors
the receiving party can somehow decode
what the antenna transmission was
okay so there's a way to encode the
the n-bit string and a way to decode uh
after their errors
uh and and today we we know how to how
to solve this kind of problem with with
these kinds of parameters
we can encode any n bit string using
order n bits
uh in such a way that as long as uh
at most 25 percent of this of the
transmission is corrupted
you can recover the original uh
transmission
so i want to say there there's there are
multiple ways to think about how the
errors happen
you can imagine that uh theirs happened
randomly
that was how this thing was studied
initially but it also makes sense to
consider
what happens when the errors are really
adversarial so you just know that you
know some
25 of the bits that are transmitted are
corrupted and you don't know anything
else
about how they're distributed so that's
that's kind of what
studied classically in coding theory
uh the setup that i that that this
tutorial is about
is when the communication is interactive
when it's not just one way
okay so now we have an interactive
protocol that's been run that's being
run between
two parties the first party knows
an input x the second party knows some
input y
and they have a conversation based on
these inputs so the first party sends
a message m1 that depends only on x
then the second party responds to the
message that depends
both on why and the messages in the past
and so on okay so in every step one of
the parties sends a message that depends
on
his input and all the messages that have
have been transmitted so
so on so far
so the question uh that we want to ask
is what's the best way to deal with
errors in in this situation
so how can we deal with errors when we
want to carry out this long conversation
he didn't say what the goal is does he
have to know x and he has to know why
we don't know what the goal is we just
like to simulate the behavior of this
protocol
so imagine that this protocol was
designed uh
under the assumption that there would be
no errors and the protocol achieves some
functionality
we just like to be able to achieve the
same functionality to simulate the
messages in this protocol
in the situation when there are errors
so you know obviously this is a
generalization of what we just talked
about in the last slide because
that you know if there's just one
message that's the case
that corresponds to the last slide if
you're just sending x across that's a
special case of such a
such an interactive protocol
okay so it's a it's a beautiful question
uh it was first studied
by schumann in the in the early 90s
uh who also gave a really beautiful
solution to this
this problem
but let me first say why why
at least i care about interactive
communication
the reason the reason is as a complexity
theorist
interactive communication shows up you
know anytime you want to measure
complexity in many situations it's hard
to imagine any computational model where
you cannot
abstractly find two parties that are
communicating with each other
interactively so for example
here's a boolean circuit it's something
that sits in your cell phone and your
and all of our computers uh so you can
always take such a circuit and
divide up the gates into two parts
uh like the left side and the right side
and now if you
think of what happens when you execute
the circuit
you see that what's going on is these
sides are interacting with each other
they're exchanging messages with each
other as they compute
okay so hiding in the circuit is an
interactive protocol
between sort of the left brain of the
circuit and the right brain of the
circuit
so a different way to phrase the
question that i just asked is
you know suppose you have two circuits
that are connected with n wires
is there some way to encode them to get
new circuits
that now have order and wires going
between them
say a small number wise going between
them
in such a way that this new circuit
achieves the same functionality as
as this this old circuit even if a large
fraction
of the wires between these two parts
fail
is there some way to do that and uh it
turns out
that there is that's what we're going to
see
okay so that's that's the question we're
after
uh is there some way to take this
protocol and encode it in such a way
that
it still works it still simulates the
original protocol even if there's
many errors in the transmissions
are there any questions about the the
model the setup
all right so
so given what we know about coding uh
you know using error correcting codes to
to encode single messages the first
thing maybe that you would think about
here is maybe we can just use those
ideas
to solve the problem in this setting
also right
maybe we can just use codes to protect
every message
in the protocol and that does work
but it doesn't work that well okay
so you could do that you could try and
use an error correcting code to protect
every message of the protocol
but the problem is because the messages
are because the protocol is interactive
an adversary just needs to ruin a single
message
in the entire protocol to ruin the
entire conversation
right so an adversary could just
concentrate all their errors onto a
single message
so imagine for example in the worst case
that the protocol just has
messages that are one bit long okay so
they're just one bit long messages and
many such messages
then no matter what error correcting
code you could use
the adversary could just concentrate
their errors onto one of those messages
which would just be one over n fraction
of the entire communication
and ruin the whole conversation
so this is not such a good idea and and
what we're going to see
are many ideas or some ideas to to solve
this problem
in a way that's better than better than
doing this
okay so here's uh before i go on let me
just give you a
broad plan for what the talks in the
tutorial are going to
be about so today what i'll talk about
is a basic solution to this problem
the solution that i'll talk about is
work of
braverman and myself which builds on the
initial ideas of shulman
and then i want to show you two
interesting applications
of of uh the solution the first is
to recovering from errors in circuits
uh in a way that's a little different
from what i showed showed you in a few a
few slides ago
the next is an application that's kind
of surprising to
metric embeddings okay
and finally i'll time permitting i'll
end with a candidate explicit solution
a can a candidate efficient solution to
this problem
on tuesday bernard will talk about some
computationally efficient solutions to
this problem
and we'll discuss topics like list
decoding
in the setting on wednesday
ranraz and bernard will talk about
interactive channel capacity
how do you figure out exactly what the
right capacity is
for a channel in the setting
and in the last talk on thursday klim
and ron gilles will talk about
list decoding uh and
multi-party communication in the setting
how do you handle more than uh
two parties
that's a broad outline and now let's
return to
uh the problem at hand so i want to
start by telling you
uh how you can what's a what's a basic
way to solve this problem
so it's hard to it's hard to think about
what every possible
communication protocol can look like so
instead what i'm going to do
is i'm going to tell you sort of a
complete problem a complete problem for
communication protocols
and we'll figure out how to solve that
problem in the presence of errors
it'll turn out that uh once you know how
to solve this problem in the presence of
errors
you can encode any protocol so that it
it
succeeds even in the presence of errors
okay
so what's the the complete problem it's
the pointer jumping problem
so here the inputs correspond to edges
in a complete binary tree so there's
sort of this underlying complete binary
tree
it has a depth end
and each party knows some subset of the
edges of this tree
okay so
every every edge at even depth in this
tree
uh every edge so every vertex in this
tree has exactly one edge coming out of
it
to a child okay so that's the promise of
the problem
and ev every such edge that comes out of
an even depth vertex
is known to the first party the second
party knows
all the edges that come out of vertices
of odd depth
okay so all of the blue edges here are
the edges that come out of
even depth vertices and they're known to
the first party and the odd
uh the second party knows all of the
edges that come out of the odd depth
vertices
and their goal is to find the unique red
blue
sort of the unique path in this tree
that's
in uh in both parties edges okay
which in this case you see is this one
so it's the
path that goes from the root to this
vertex and then to this vertex
that's all okay so there's a trivial
n-bit communication protocol for this
problem which is that
the first party can send a bit to say
what the indicate what the first edge is
there's that he knows that comes out of
the root
then the second party can respond with a
bit that says
what the second edges of the path and so
on
right so in this way after n bits of
communication
they'll have figured out what the the
path is that goes from the root to the
to a leaf industry
all right so the reason that this
problem
it's the first time i say so so what
we're going to spend most of the talk
on is trying to understand how can we
solve this problem
when some of the transmissions of the of
the parties are corrupted
that's what we like to do we're given
these the parties know these edges and
they're given
this input and they would like to solve
this problem efficiently but some of the
symbols
some of the some of their transmissions
may be corrupted adversarially
so the reason that this problem is sort
of complete for
arbitrary for communication problem
protocols is
you know given any communication
protocol you can think of
each of these vertices as representing a
partial transcript
of the messages of the players and
this edge is representing what the next
player would say
okay so kind of this this input captures
the behavior of the protocol on all
possible inputs
and in all possible situations and given
given that behavior
you know the first party knows how he'll
behave on these nodes
and the second party knows how he would
behave when the protocol is in
in these states so given that
description we'd like to figure out what
the outcome of the protocol will be
okay so this kind of captures uh pretty
much what any
protocol does
okay but we'll just now focus on this
problem
just make it a bit i mean i understand
the other one can you make an explicit
statement in what sense is this is
complete uh it's complete in the sense
that
if you have i mean there's parameters
but ignoring parameters if you solve
this problem
uh uh if you can figure out how to solve
this problem with say communication
order n
and sum error rate then that means that
you can take any protocol
whose communication is n and uh
simulate simulated by another protocol
with communication order n
even in the presence of uh some fraction
of errors
maybe it's easier to say that for any
communication protocol that
runs in the end rounds for exist in the
instance of input for pointer jumping
problem of depth too and
which solves this progress exactly yeah
okay
yeah so for any any communication
protocol there's a way to reduce it
to this problem
with a factor of two
okay so so that's why it's enough to
just think about this problem uh
so here's the plan uh for for how i'm
going to show you how to solve this
problem
so it'll turn out to be much easier to
think about solving this problem
not using a protocol that has bits as
its transmissions
but symbols from a very large alphabet
so that's what i'll do first i'll first
show you how to solve this problem
problem if
i'm allowed to send you symbols from a
very large alphabet
uh and then we'll show then i'll i'll
explain why
uh the same solution essentially works
with a smaller alphabet
the same solution also gives you a
solution with uh with just
bits as your transmission
so to use the large alphabet so
so for now we're just going to imagine
that we're allowed to send symbols from
a huge alphabet
uh so given that i'm going to first
explain just the original protocol the
the trivial protocol that we talked
about that that exchange is end bits
uh but uh i'm going to explain how to
run it using a huge alphabet okay i'm
going to make it a little worse
and this will be helpful when we try and
make the protocol resilient to errors
so here's a different way to view
exactly the same protocol
so every alphabet symbol is now going to
represent
a distinct edge in this picture okay
distinct edge of this tree
so that's a huge alphabet besides
something like 2 to the n
and one way to view that protocol is
you can view it like this in every step
a party announces an edge and
then the edge they announced is the
unique edge that kind of extends
the path that's given uh in the set of
edges that have been announced so far
so in the first step the first party
announces this edge
okay then the second party announces
this edge
and now you know a union b form uh this
path
and the first party knows how to extend
that path so the first party announces
this edge and and and so on
right so in every step uh someone who
can extend the path
that they know about so far announces
the edge that helps extend it and
eventually they find the belief that
they're interested in
okay so that's the trivial protocol
now what happens when there errors the
problem
is that from the first party's
perspective
he's not entirely sure what edges were
announced by the second party
right because some of the messages you
get are corrupted
so for example it might be that the
first party announces this edge
and then the second party announces this
edge but the first party receives this
edge
because there's an error so
now the adversary not only chooses which
symbols to corrupt but
he gets to choose what they are
corrupted to yeah the adversary is all
powerful he knows
everything the players know and he
corrupts in an arbitrary way
so you know the adversary would not uh
say
that the second party announced you know
something far away because then the
first party would know that that's an
error
right the adversary will say something
like this this is what the second party
said
i don't understand how this is different
from binary case
it's not different yet but my solution
is going to be a large alphabet solution
my first solution
right now i'm explaining why it's
failing
uh so i've just made things worse with a
large alphabet because
keeping in mind that my solution will
later exploit the large alphabet
so so the reason it doesn't work is is
exactly this right the first party
doesn't know
what's going on so now the first party
might announce this
edge but the adversary can come in again
and corrupt
that transmission and make the second
party think that the first party
actually announced this edge
so this way the adversary can kind of
derail this conversation
to make the party sort of just exchange
useless information
so that's kind of why just the trivial
protocol does not work
as is
so we're going to try and patch up this
protocol
to make it work and the way we're going
to do that is we're going to use
a beautiful combinatorial object that
was invented
by shulman for this purpose called a
tree code
so let me explain what it is and then
we'll
see some of its nice properties and then
finally use it to solve that problem
so what is a tree code it's a a dre tree
code
is a dairy tree where all the edges of
the tree are labeled by
symbols from some alphabet
so all the edges of the tree are labeled
by symbols from an alphabet
and the property we want of this
labeling
is the following distance property
if you take any two vertices u and v in
the tree
which are at the same depth
and look at the path that goes from u to
the least common ancestor of u and v and
v
to the least common ancestor of unb then
this path has a large hamming distance
on it
so take any two vertices u and v which
are the same depth
and look at their common ancestor here
and then if you look at the labels
uh from that ancestor to you and that
ancestor to v
and then just write down these labels uh
as a string
the hamming distance between these two
strings must be large
okay so the distance of the the code is
one minus epsilon if the relative
distance between these two strings
for every such u and v is at least one
minus epsilon
it means the hamming distance between a
and b is at least 1 minus epsilon times
the length of
a and b
okay so uh
so that's that's what a tree code is
it's a labeling of the tree that has
this property
now one way to achieve this is to just
label
every edge in the tree with a completely
distinct alphabet
symbol right then everything will be
different
and and you'll have this property with
one here
but the interesting thing is that you
can actually do this labeling with
a really small size alphabet so what
schulman shows is that
you only need an alphabet of size that's
d to the power of something that depends
on epsilon to achieve such a labeling
so the crucial thing here is the size of
this alphabet does not depend
on the number of vertices in the tree it
only depends on d
and and epsilon
and it's it's it's not uh trivial to
construct
uh such a such a tree code uh for
example it's easy to see that just a
completely random labeling will not work
nevertheless shulman shows that you know
he shows a different way to sample the
labels
in such a way that that you get such a
tree code with hyper
with good probability
so that's so i'm not going to show you
how to sample a tree code or how to
construct such a thing
it is a major open problem to actually
give an explicit construction of such a
labeling
okay and that's what i'll discuss maybe
the end of the talk
but for now let's assume that we have a
tree code so we have a labeling of the
tree
with these properties and see how to use
it uh
to solve the problem we care about
so let me just say so here are some nice
properties of of of tree codes
uh once you have them so imagine that
the first party
wants to send you as his message
so he wants to send the name of the
vertex u as this message
so how how can you do that the first
party can then just
you know send the labels on the path
that lead up to you
in the cheat code so the first party
sends that
and then then what you can tell is that
if the so the second party might receive
something that's
that's not exactly what the first party
sent they might have errors
but what you do know is that if the
second party decoded
v instead of you by just finding you
know the vertex
at that depth that has the most
agreement with the messages that you saw
then it must be the case that the number
of errors
in this interval here
must be very large it must be that the
fraction of errors
uh in this part where u and v disagree
must be at least
one minus epsilon over two times the
length of that part
so that's the crucial feature we'll use
if the second party decoded v instead of
you then you know something
about the part where you and v disagree
the suffix where you and v disagree
there have to be lots of errors
in just that part
is that clear to everyone
maybe you want to ask a question and
help why
are you because i'm counting the number
of errors
the distance in this part is one minus
epsilon times
the uh the length here but you know with
50
errors you could interpolate between two
strings right so
likely would be coding yes so what i'm
what i'm every time
the the way i'm going to do decoding is
you know the first party sends this path
and the second party will find the
vertex v
that's closest to this path in hamming
distance
right whose labels are closest in
hamming distance
and that's going to be the decoding
algorithm
okay so the point is that if the
fraction of errors here you know the
first part you send
you here if the fraction errors was
smaller than this number
then you then you would definitely be
closer than v
okay because you and v agree and on all
the labels in this part
so there they're kind of doing exactly
the same and the only part the place
where they're doing differently is
is in this part of the string so the
fraction if the fraction of errors
they're smaller
then you would be more likely than than
v
okay so that's the key property that
we'll use
another thing i want to point out is
that tree codes
imply the existence of classical error
correcting codes
okay so i want to say that you know if
if you have a tree code then you also
have a classical
error correcting code and and that's uh
for example given just by this
construction suppose you want to encode
some string x uh that's of length n
then here's how you can encode it what
you can send
is send the symbols that correspond to
the path that's given by
x concatenated with a bunch of ones
so say you have x here and n ones
okay so you want to send x
you send all the symbols up to x and
then send all of these symbols too
and then this forms a good error
correcting code because
you know if x and y are not the same
then the tree
three code property means that if you
look at the labels of x
with all these ones and the labels of y
with all these ones
then it must be that you have a very
large hamming distance
in this part of the string
so these two these the code words that
correspond to the labels of these paths
will be very far apart in hamming
distance
but they're they're sort of stronger
than the normal codes
uh and another nice thing about them
versus normal codes is
you know usually in error correcting
code if you have a message x and you
want to send it
you have to see the entire message and
then encode the entire message
into a code word right using tree codes
you can sort of
start transmitting right away so you get
the first symbol of x
you send a label you get the second
symbol of x you send another label
and if there are no errors then after n
steps
the receiver already knows what you were
sending
if there are errors the receiver needs
to wait a little more
to decode okay so it's sort of a
really faster way of encoding messages
than using an error correcting code
okay so those are three codes now let's
try and use them to
to solve the problem we care about so
again this is the problem
uh and the way we're going to solve this
problem
is we're going to essentially run the
trivial protocol we talked about
except we'll use treat codes to encode
and decode the
the messages that are being transmitted
okay
so it's just a reminder of what the
trivial protocol was we just like to
announce
in every step the edge that announced
that extends the path that we know about
so here's how we'll use three codes
so both parties will ahead of time know
some construction of a tree code
and that's what's drawn here
and the vertices in this tree code will
be interpreted
as subsets of the edges of of this input
tree
okay in the following way
the vertex that's the root that's at the
root of the tree code
corresponds to the empty set of edges
okay
all the vertices that uh at the next
level of the tree code
corresponds to uh edges of size at most
one in in this set of edges
okay so in general
every vertex at depth k in the tree code
is going to correspond to a set of edges
in this picture
which has at most k edges in it
so i'll give you an example and then
maybe we'll be a little more clear
so suppose you initially uh in in your
protocol
the parties were sending messages like
this so those were the edges of the
tree and the first party was ascending
one
then the second party was responding
with edge number four
and then the first party was responding
again with edge number nine
then now in the in the new protocol that
uses tree codes
the parties will do this instead
they know the street code which
corresponds all the vertices correspond
to sets of edges
and the first party wants to send a one
okay
so that that corresponds to saying that
his set of edges is going to change from
the empty set
to announcing a one so he'll send the
symbol a
which is the symbol labeling the edge
that goes from
the empty set to the set containing one
okay so then a now the second party
wants to announce four
uh but she doesn't just send four in the
in the clear instead she looks at the
tree code and she says okay so she wants
to make
her set of edges that she's announced so
far before
so she'll send the symbol b
yeah so what's the attitude i mean
what's the degree of the three code that
you're gonna use it's
two to the n so far right now
okay so i see so so n is that the
protocol and
the protocol itself is binary but the
three code is two to the end
yeah yeah yeah so as i said for now i'm
just going to assume you know that for
free i'm going to use this huge alphabet
and later i'll show you that actually
all everything will work even with the
binary
uh messages but that'll be more
complicated so for now let's just uh
understand this but but i'm not asking i
mean i'm asking about the degree
code those will both be the same so
eventually what will happen
is both the tree code will become binary
and the alphabet will become
small okay so for now the tree code has
a degree that's exponential in in n
and the alphabet symbols are huge but
eventually this problem will go away
more questions
okay so one thing to keep in mind here
is that what's going on
is uh each party is sort of using the
street code
uh independently in the sense that you
know so
in the first set the the party sends
eight to say that he's announced
one and then in the third step here the
party announces nine
so to do that he just looks at he just
wants to change the set of edges that
he's announced from one to one nine
so he announces he just sends the symbol
f
which corresponds to saying that now
he's adding the
the edge nine to the set of edges that
he's announced
is it important that they use the same
no it's not but they need to know what
each other is using
one line is there because this is
consistent
with something right i mean there is no
uh 117 i've defined it so far actually
that's exactly how we'll save the
alphabet size
but as i've defined it so far every set
of size two is here
okay eventually we'll reduce alphabet
size by saying that not every set is
possible
okay so each party is kind of using the
cheat code independently to
to encode their messages uh and they're
basically trying to encode the set of
edges that they've announced
so far that's how we want to think about
this
so here's how the protocol runs now
so i'm going to describe the protocol
from the perspective of the first party
okay so from the perspective of the
first party he's gonna keep track of two
things
so he knows so far the edges that he's
announced
and these he really knows right the
adversary cannot
corrupt his memory so he knows the edges
he's announced
but he doesn't know exactly what edges
were announced by the second party
so instead he uses a proxy which is this
b prime that i've drawn there
he keeps track of kind of what is his
best guess for the vertex
in this tree that corresponds to to the
second party's messages
and this decodes to some subset of edges
okay so when the protocol starts the
first party so initially a and b prime
are both empty
and then the first party announces this
edge
and maybe this the second party sends a
send some message
which the first party probably received
incorrectly
but the first party just decodes that
message to find the vertex is the most
likely vertex in in this layer of the
tree code
which tells them some subset of edges in
this case it's the empty set of edges
then the first party looks at a and b
prime and tries to extend the path right
so a and b prime contains so far only
this one edge which means the first part
he does not know
how to extend the path so he kind of
sends the symbol null
okay in the in the clear would be the
symbol null
basically he wants to move to the set in
the next level it corresponds exactly
the set of edges that he's at already
he doesn't have any new edge to add but
he still sends something in the tree
code
and then the second party responds with
something which now the first party may
be decodes to this set of edges
it might decode to something that's
completely inconsistent with what
he knew before but that's fine he just
continues greedily so now he sees
he sees some other edge on that side he
just ignores it
but he he just he does see two edges
here
which he can extend so he announces this
edge
and then the second party responds to
something which might again radically
change
the set of red edges from the first
party's perspective
so now the first party will announce
this edge
and so on so maybe now they're just
changed to this
and then this now the first party has
something to say so he announces this
edge
and the second party says something else
maybe changes it to this now the first
party announces this edge
so kind of in every step the first party
knows exactly what he
has announced and he has some guests for
what the second party announced which
might be shifting around
a lot but he just tries to reveal
information that helps
them proceed in every set when you say
he announces this edge
you mean an extension all the edges that
he sent earlier to
together with that no just
the the set he's at right now he's
keeping track of his location in the
tree code
which corresponds to some set of edges
he's just going to add a new edge to
that set
which will correspond to some child of
that vertex
and send the label of the the the tree
code label
so in every step he's kind of just uh
taking one step here that corresponds to
adding one edge to the
okay so that's how the protocol goes and
it just goes for some amount of time
and hopefully eventually what's going to
happen is the picture will look
something like this
that from the first party perspective
he'll have announced the true
red blue path in the in the tree that's
what we want to prove
okay so the protocol is uh pretty simple
and we just need to now make sure that
it actually works
i i'm not 100 the the red player
he sees the latest transmission from
the blue player and then he forgets
everything he saw
before and no no no so the red player
sees
the latest transmission he knows all the
transmissions of the blue players
he decodes this entire string to a
vertex in the tree code
okay so that's why the the the blue from
the blue players perspective the red
edges
might change quite a bit because after
receiving one more symbol here
it might change something in the path in
the past by a lot
so like because most likely was decoding
so like
by changing once i tried
any other questions
yeah that's the case how come the the
new decoded message is always a child
of the blue why doesn't the blue
guy why can't you proceed always oh the
blue guy
is not doing any this is the perspective
of the first party
okay so from the perspective the first
party he knows a
exactly he's doing the decoding only on
b to the code b prime
from the perspective of the second party
the blue edges are shifting all over the
place
the second party knows b exactly and is
just doing the decoding to decode uh
so this view that i've drawn here is
only the first party's view
so some red messages the way the blue
player sees it
make no sense right yeah that's right
and those he ignores
or he tries to no he as i described he
just dumbly continues
tries to reinterpret by allowing more
arrows so
no he just reinterprets he everything
you know decodes some vertex in the tree
code which corresponds to sunset so he
puts that set on
it might be a crazy set here that
doesn't make any sense but the protocol
still makes sense
yeah i think one thing they try to
clarify is that
in each step the blue player looks at
what the red player has said now he had
some interpretation of what that meant
in the previous round he forgets that
interpretation
but he remembers it remembers all the
transmissions yeah decodes
that the whole sequence of transmissions
that's right
yeah so the the actual decoding from the
previous step is completely forgotten
he just looks at this transmissions and
re-decodes them into the tree code
it's like history
that was more of a poet maybe
okay so is everybody clear with the
protocol
all right um so now you know the hard
part is to figure out why does this
actually work right because it seems uh
crazy so in order to analyze this so
so let me introduce some notation so in
each round of the protocol
there are kind of four sets that are in
play four sets of edges
there's the sets a and b which are the
true sets of edges that have been
announced so far
by each party and then there are the
decodings a prime and b prime
right the second party decodes a prime
from from the transmissions and the
first party decodes b
prime and these might not be
might not might be really far from a and
b
so one one thing that's really useful to
keep in mind uh one parameter that's
really useful is
this parameter t of k which is the the
time
at which the first k edges on the
correct path
have been announced okay they have been
included in a union b
okay so let me just draw a picture so
it's clear
so now this is a different picture from
what i had before now these are the true
sets a and b not not the the
not the decoded sets okay so as the
protocol runs
you know in the first step you know
surely the first party will announce the
first edge
so the first step already is t1
then maybe this is what happens in the
second step they both announced
some crazy edges because of theirs
uh and at this point the second party
announced
uh the second edge in the in the correct
path
okay so that's that's t2 that's the
point i'll call t2
so at this point one of the parties has
announced the third edge
in in the correct path uh but this is
not yet t3
because this sorry one of the parties
announced the fourth edge
uh but when when all first all of the
first four edges have been announced
that's when
t4 happens okay so in general tk is the
time when
all of the first k edges have been
announced by both parties
but essentially how
so that's that's just a number that's
that's that's uh that's interesting so
you know if you want to argue that the
protocol is correct
uh it better be the case that tn
happens before the particle ends right
so that's definitely one thing we need
to ensure but that itself does not
guarantee that
that that the parties know that this
happened okay so that's not enough
but that's definitely necessary so let's
just try and think about
that so the intuition is
basically what we're going to try and
show is that
if there's a large gap between tk and tk
plus one
so if at this point all the first k
edges have been announced
but then for a long time the next edge
is not announced
then there must be a large number of
errors in this interval
that's what we're going to try and try
and argue
okay announcing an edge means so as the
pr as the parties continue
the first part is maintaining the set a
which is the set of edges that he's
announced
right and every step the party's uh
adding and adding an edge potentially
adding an edge to the set a
and then decoding b prime which is this
guess for the set of edges that have
been announced by the second part
that's that's what i mean is that clear
no no not just k edges being announced
but k
edges on this correct path so there's
this
correct red blue path and i'm interested
in how many of those edges have been
announced
so some of the so at this point for
example only one
one edge has been announced from the
correct correct path oh this is b
prime but you know the first party
announced this edge and that edge is not
on the correct path
okay so i'm not counting that so when i
say tk i mean
the time at which the first k edges
on the correct path are included in a
union b
but that doesn't mean they the other
party actually
got it correctly that's right that's
right
yeah so it just means that someone has
said it okay
okay so this is this is what i'm gonna
try and argue is that
there can you know if there can be big
gaps between tk and tk plus one
it might have been that everybody uh
that that the first k i just have been
announced
but still we have to wait a long time
for the k plus first edge to be
announced
but this this only this only happens if
the adversary inserts a lot of errors
into this part of the communication
okay so in order to understand
how that can happen let's define a
second quantity
so the quantity is uh mr
and this is the time up to which the
decodings are consistent
in time in round r so what do i mean so
say we're at round r and these are the
four sets
uh that are relevant to this run so a
and b are the sets of edges that have
been announced so far
and a and b a prime and b prime are the
decodings of the parties
that corresponds to these sets so in
general a prime and b prime will not be
equal to a and b
right so so they but they will be equal
up to some point
so like b prime and b are two vertices
in the in the tree code
and there's some least common ancestor
that b prime and b have
so m r is the sort of the maximum of the
two
least common ancestors
so in round r mr is like uh before
mr the the decodings are consistent
that's what it means
so if you look before mr b and b prime
are the same
the decoding is is correct and before mr
a and a prime are the same
theirs only happen after mr theirs isn't
the decoding only happen
after mr
so this can go up and down this can go
up and down yeah so it's not monotone at
all it might be that in r plus one mr
goes farther back or even forward
so here's how we'll prove that the
protocol succeeds
so what's written here proves that the
protocol succeeds after n over epsilon
rounds okay so let me
say what it means so it says that if the
error rate is small enough
then after n over epsilon rounds if you
look at
m of the last round we'll prove that
that's at least
t of n which means
that t of n will occur if this is the
last round t of n will occur somewhere
here
in other words both parties will have
decoded
the first uh the the entire all the n
edges of the correct path correctly and
that means that
they both know what the outcome of the
the protocol is
because not no other no other edges can
change their
belief about what happened in the in the
real protocol
once they know the the all energies is
the correct path
so there are two abstinence
for the communication it's the same
epsilon so
we'll use a tree code with distance one
minus epsilon
and the error rate for the communication
will be one quarter minus epsilon
so since we said before the mfr can
we'll prove this no matter what happens
in the protocol at this round this will
be true
no but so they know this is something
i'm still
so do they know that they know so they
at the moment they both have a
path that's consistent and it's true but
how what's their proof that they've
accomplished their goal
do they know this yeah they do because
what they will do so here's the here's
what the
parties are going to do they will run
for this many rounds
and at the last in in when the first
party terminates he has a set
a and b prime and together these give
some edges in the tree and the product
the the proof will guarantee that there
will be a unique path that hits one leaf
in this in this and that's the leaf he's
going to output
the theorem the theorem proves that
they'll always
have just this one path which indicates
what the simulation is
so in principle b prime could have two
inconsistent edges right so he would
have like two
passes already
how confused can be a set of
inconsistent edges including two red
edges
starting from the same vertex good uh
actually
yeah actually so we will forbid any such
inconsistencies
in the tree coin that's easy to do so
we'll always always make sure that the
edges
uh the vertices in the tree code only
correspond to
edges that don't you know come from the
same place okay good
yeah that's a good point so eventually
you know yeah
so every every vertex here is going to
correspond to some
set of edges that could be could
possibly be a subset of the inputs to
to the second party
okay so this is what we're going to
prove
um
i'm sort of running out of time but
because but i think it's good we'll
spend more time here
and less on the rest of what i plan to
talk about
uh so
okay so that's that's our goal now to
prove that
so here's here's the first lemma that's
useful for this
and this lemma just follows from the fa
from the property of three codes
okay so lemma says that the fraction of
errors in the
for for in any round r
the fraction of errors in the interval m
r plus 1 to r must be at least
1 minus epsilon over 4. okay and this
just follows from the tree code property
because if you look at the interval r
to m r plus one that corresponds to
exactly you know this kind of uh part in
the tree code
and the the tree chord property we
talked about before says
that this means that this the second
player's transmissions must have
experienced an error rate of one minus
epsilon over two
okay so the second player experience is
one minus epsilon
over two fraction of errors that means
overall they're experiencing one minus
epsilon over four
fraction of errors
good so that's one lemma the second
lemon
says that if r plus one is less than t k
then it must be the case that m r is
less than t k minus one
in other words sort of the r's and the
mr r m rs
pairs interleave with the tk tk minus
one pairs
and maybe it'll be clear when you see
the proof it's a simple proof
suppose it doesn't happen suppose the
picture looks more like this
there's a round r and m r that are
between
t k minus one and tk then
this contradicts the behavior of the
protocol because
at round r if mr is after tk minus 1
that means both parties know the first k
minus 1 edge is
correct so that means one of them will
announce immediately the
the k edge
okay so if this happens then tk must
follow right after
round r that's exactly what the dilemma
says
so it says that if you if you uh
if if r is sort of much before tk then
mr must be
before tk minus one so
in each round both people three yeah
so question so tk is when the k page is
announced right but the other person may
not
hear that engine that's true but because
mr is after tk minus one
that means that both parties have
decoded after the first k minus one
edges correctly
okay so tk the k minus first edge is
announced here
but at some point later it's only now
that uh is it clear what i'm saying
so i mean maybe i'm confused about what
does tk mean that both of us have to
agree on the first cape
it just means both of us have announced
them have tried to transmit the first k
edges between the two of us it doesn't
mean that we've decoded them correctly
it just means they've been enough
contains the cable
exactly the set a unique
contains it and in this proof we're
using the fact that because m r is after
t k minus one
even the sets a prime and b prime
contain the first
k minus one edges
okay so with these two lemmas now we're
basically uh
down to the proof uh so we want to prove
that in the last round the m of the last
round is at least
t of n so that's what we argued would be
enough to argue that the protocol is
correct
suppose that doesn't happen then then
the picture
should sort of look like this right if m
of the last round is less than t of n
uh applying lemma2
we get that sort of uh m of the
the sorry if there's
i'll explain the intuition i think
there's some off by one
applications in this slide but
uh the intuition is uh if you look at
r and m r then they must sort of go past
t of n minus one
and then by the first lemma we know that
there's a higher error rate in this
region
um and then we can apply the same
argument to
uh to this new r so
set r to be this new m of this number
and that number is now less than
t n minus one which means by uh
lemma two m of this number must be
before t
n minus two
so in this way we can kind of cover you
cannot
do this forever eventually you you'll
end up because you run out of teas
okay so you cover the entire uh
transcript here
with these error regions and that's uh
that's the idea the proof
so so basically what you find is you you
find
sort of between these r and m r's
there's a lot of errors
and you know in the proof what happens
is there's a little bit of you know
there are these
indices which are off by one so there
are little intervals here with one or
two rounds where there are no errors
okay but for most of the protocol you
for most of the
the time interval you can find intervals
with lots of errors
and and that that will show that so if
this didn't happen then
overall there must be lots of errors
throughout the course
because you need what your original
protocol is
yeah yeah so exactly so you need the the
blow up and the communication to be
large enough so that these black parts
are not a large fraction of the entire
communication
so that that's the uh basic idea
and now uh as natty said uh
oh okay so so this proves the theorem
that if you use this huge alphabet
then you can solve the problem even if
they're one minus epsilon over four
errors and now uh
you can reduce the alphabet size by
realizing that actually you don't need
to encode all possible sets of edges
here
but only those edges that could show up
uh
and you can reduce this the size of the
the you know the number of sets that
show up is actually much smaller
so you know one thing is uh what you
said that you cannot have two red edges
from the same place that's one thing
that cannot happen but um
another observation you can make is that
you know if this is the set of edges
that have been announced so far
like in every step each party will
announce only an edge that's close to
some edge of his
of the edge that he announced before
right like from a's perspective no
matter what edges set of edges b prime
that he sees
he might announce you know this edge or
this edge or this edge or this edge
there's no way he'll announce you know
some edge that's here
because he'll never find a path within
his set of edges that gets close enough
to that edge so this reduces the space
of edges by a lot
because the total number of edges a has
announced so far
is only polynomial okay so that's
basically that reduces alphabet size
to something that's polynomial in uh
in n
and then finally you can actually reduce
the the alphabet
of which to just be bits by doing sort
of the
the most naive thing you could imagine
uh instead of
instead of sending edges we'll send
encode those the names of those edges in
binary and transmit them
bit by bit using a tree code okay so
that's the protocol
uh so in every step kind of a player
might be in the middle of transmitting
the name of an edge
or might have been done if he's in the
middle he continues transmitting
okay your alphabet is still not
binary because you have the three
oh that's right that's right good yeah
so the
right so we'll encode the using a binary
but then the tree code is uh still using
constant size alphabet
right eventually you can even get it
down to binary by using a tree code that
has binary strings as the labels
okay but for a constant size alphabet
you you just announce uh sort of the
bits of the names of the edges
and and then you might you know at first
you might think that this might cause
a log factor blow up in the
communication
because you know each message might be
login bits
but it turns out that that can be
avoided okay so it turns out that you
can
the messages we're sending can always be
encoded
in such a way that you're kind of
sending
each edge that you're sending is like
you need to say this is an edge that's a
neighbor of this other edge that
announced before so you send in binary
the offset
from the last edge you announced and you
continue in this way
and then you can show using a convexity
argument that
the total contribution of the the bits
is
is actually not not too much it's only a
constant factor
yeah this is a variable length code then
that's being used
for so when i announce the next
edge binary is the binary string of
different length or is always the same
length
no it's a it's it's of different length
so sometimes i'll
the label the edge i'll choose i'll have
to state more things involved that's
right
moving to variable length code is what
does this happen uh
i don't know what variable length code
means but in every step you announce
the you're announcing the uh you want to
send a string which is which
might be a different length from the
string you were sending before but
you'll use
a tree code the same q code that we
talked about to send encode each part of
that string
do i know in advance how long the string
will be for
at that stage i mean basically just you
want to say go x steps back and go to
the right child
yeah and you want to encode this in log
x plus constant number of bits
if we use uh error cards usually for
error collection codes above that record
to like preserve
the error rate when we go to binary from
from the huge alphabet uh
in some that's one you can do that but
it turns out you can or you can just
build a tree code
that has the binary strings on it which
basically is doing
that in some sense
more questions
okay uh so that's pretty much all i was
gonna say
uh about about uh encoding protocol so
it turns out you can tolerate
an error rate of one minus epsilon over
four if you use an alphabet size of uh
constant
and if you want to use a binary alphabet
you can tolerate an error rate of one
minus epsilon over eight
uh and there's sort of a some good
reason why
it's hard to go past their rate of one
over four although bernard will
talk about one way to go past this air
rate uh
and that's because you know if if the
model
for communication is that in every step
the players agree about who is going to
speak
in that step then intuitively
one of the in any protocol in any
simulation that you construct
one of the parties will be speaking half
the time
and the adversary can always focus all
of
uh their errors on that party uh and if
with a 50
error rate on that party they can
corrupt any such protocol
okay so one over four sort of the
natural uh
uh point at which you should not be able
to recover
for binary we don't know if one over
eight is the
right number but
okay so any questions about this before
i
move on
so i've gone much longer than i intended
to i was going to tell you two
applications
and a candidate construction of tree
codes
but maybe i'll skip this first
application i'll just tell you
roughly what it is so i talked about how
uh
how g-codes can be used to encode
circuits with errors in this way if you
have two circuits that are talking to
each other
but here's maybe a little uh more
a surprising model for errors that three
codes can also be used to solve
suppose you have a circuit and the
circuits
now so the reason we got to this is we
were thinking about
you know what kind of adversarial errors
can you tolerate in circuits
which at first you think you know
nothing because if there's a corruption
at the output gate
the whole circuit is ruined right
but uh if you think about if you think
about what corruptions
can be tolerated but what can't you know
you notice something interesting
you know obviously if if you replace the
output gate with a constant then the
circuit is ruined
if you negate the output gate then the
entire circuit is ruined
but what if you flip an and gate for an
or gate
okay then it's not clear it's not clear
you know one such error may not ruin the
circuit right like in this circuit
the computation is still fine because
there was one one here it doesn't matter
if it's an end
or okay and actually what we proved is
that
these kinds of errors you can actually
tolerate quite well
so what we showed
using tree codes is that
you can always take any circuit of depth
d and
encode it to get a new circuit of depth
order d
such that the new circuit computes
exactly the same thing as the old
circuit
as long as at most say 10 percent
uh of every input output path is
corrupted with these and or switches so
adversary is allowed to take on any
input output path and corrupt
up to 10 percent of the gates there by
flipping ants to ores or
or sands and the circuit the the
resilient circuit will still work
and what about the size there's no
control on size
yeah so that's actually a really
interesting open question is to
do the same thing with bounding the size
instead of the depth
so i'll skip i think actually i think
it's a beautiful question it's also
connected to codes in in a different way
but i'll skip it
so i'll just try to quickly tell you uh
another application
and this is a to the problem of uh
constructing metric
embeddings so the problem here is uh so
it
specifically shows up and you want to
try and embed trees into l1
so what does that mean so here's a tree
and what we would like to do is map
all the vertices of the tree to
points in euclidean space in such a way
that
the this the distance is the l1
distances in the euclidean space
correspond to the distances
on the tree okay so for example here's
one way to do this mapping for this tree
so i've mapped each of these vertices to
these points in euclidean space
and you can see that the the l1 distance
between these two vertices is one
and that's the same uh i mean in the
tree it's one and in the
in the euclidean space in a l1 it's also
one
okay in the same way the distance from
this to this is two
and it's the same in the tree so we'd
like to be able to do that
for every for every tree
that's that's the question and
the thing we're trying to optimize is
we're trying to minimize
the number of dimensions you need to use
in euclidean space
in order to achieve this
so okay one thing that's easy to do is
you can always embed the line
using one dimension right so that's one
special case it's easy to
handle
and then maybe perhaps the next example
that you would think of
is how do you encode the complete binary
tree
right that's the other extreme it
completely branches
so let's talk about that and this is
exactly where you can use tree codes
so i'd like to encode this into l1
but i'd like to have a very small
dimension
so let's let's do it by by first let's
put a labeling on this on the on the
edges of this tree
that correspond to a tree code okay so
we know that you can label it
using a constant size alphabet if you
want a constant relative distance
then here's the idea here's how you do
the embedding
you put the root of the tree at the
origin
okay the number of dimensions here is
going to be log n
if there are n vertices in this in this
picture
and then this vertex will be uh
will be mapped to the point uh e2
followed by zeros where e2 is
uh a unit vector in k dimensional space
uh in direction two okay so each one of
these coordinates is a k dimensional
vector
and they're going to be login login such
coordinates
so this this coordinate goes to e 2 0 0
0. this one will go to e 2 e 3
0 0 0. okay
so you basically use the labels of the
tree code
to to figure out where to embed things
just by concatenating the labels
using basis vectors
okay so now you see so what is the
distance between these two
uh it should be two and it is right so
these two already share e2 in the first
coordinate
and they disagree on this one has e1
here and e3 here
so the l1 distance between these two
vectors is two
which is exactly the tree code which is
exactly the distance in the tree
right one two so in general
uh it turns out that the tree code
property is exactly what you want
to make sure that this embedding
preserves the distances
at least up to some error so this
this construction is used so to show
that
uh you can embed any tree using
or or login distortion dimensions one
percent
yes yeah so the the
the distance of the tree code uh will
the fact that sometimes these two
the labels are equal will will give an
error
in in the in the in the relationship
between the distance in the l1 and
distance versus
distance in the graphs this error is
necessary
but this idea is actually was actually
used to then uh by
uh lee mesme and maharami to show how to
handle
or i wrote all graphs but i meant trees
you can actually handle all
trees uh in log n dimensions
okay so it's another reason why if you
could construct explicit tree codes that
would
you know uh translate to giving express
embeddings this is another motivation to
sell you this thing
is this the only way known to them but
achieve this embedding before this
construction there was something that
did log squared n dimensions and that
uses different ideas
but uh with log n dimensions this is the
only way as far as i know
trees yeah everything is for trees
no i made a mistake that's what i said
yeah this this actually should be trees
this is all trees
oh this is this is a binary tree
and arbitrary trees can be paths so what
happens arbitrary you have to mix the
two ideas that i talked about
sometimes you have a path and then you
don't want to add more dimensions
and sometimes you have something that
fans out a lot and so the final
construction sort of mixes these two
ideas
in a way it's it's complicated to get uh
show that for all trees you can embed it
into login dimensions
what's the best mountain for all groups
uh
i'm not sure it's
something like n to the power one over
i think it's polynomial in diamond
so it's polynomial n is that right
because it follows from lower bounds for
dimension reduction at l1
okay so that's at least one thing uh
maybe i'll just stop by uh after i show
you this candidate construction of
tricos which was recently uh
suggested by uh moore and shulman
so this is a construction that they
believe to be true i think they even use
computers to check
that for some number of for some depth
it is a tree code
but there's a there's a conjecture on
uh there's a conjecture about some
exponential sum
that if true would imply that this is a
tree code
so what is the construction so
the basic idea is every vertex of the
tree will be associated with
some point some complex number of unit
magnitude okay so some point in the
circle
uh and then the the actual labels will
be given
by seeing uh sort of which quadrant that
point
is in okay so
the label of this is two because i
is in the second quadrant okay the label
of this is four because z is in
the fourth quadrant okay so how are the
these uh complex numbers picked they're
picked recursively
by solving this equation so the root is
labeled one
and then the next two guys are the two
square roots of
one cubed which are plus one and minus
one
and then the two children of minus one
are the two square roots of minus one
which is minus one cubed okay and so on
uh so what happens is at the second
level you get
the the both the second roots of unity
at the next level you get all the fourth
roots of unity
and so on but they're permeated in some
way
so you know if you like number theory
then
uh that's something you can think about
all right so i'll stop there i'll i'll
just say so
for me the most interesting uh question
that's related to all the problems i
talked about here is can you construct
tricos explicitly can you find an
algorithm that actually
constructs a tree code thanks
uh i mean the sampling works with 99
probability but there's no way to
certify that what you got
is correct
the way how many will construct
something will not be
99 correct no it will be
i mean his convolution construction if
you use uh
yeah if you use uh you know larger as
you increase the field size the
probability of success
will be higher and higher
in this context a bigger problem is not
just even if i could write down a tree
code
how do i decode it right if the tree
code has like pseudo-random structure
and i want to find the path that's like
closest to a given string
good luck doing that right even if i can
compute every label on the pass
very efficiently the coding would still
be
we're at the same point when uh they
first constructed random codes we need
to
come with ideas to to build these things
and decode them